翻訳: YORIKO NODA
校正: Yuri Ueda
私は 大学に行くのが
当たり前の高校にいました
その時の私が これです
とても 笑えるでしょう？
(笑)
当時 先生が 進路について
こう言いました
「大学を選ぶときは
偏差値で安易に選んではいかん」
「将来 就きたい仕事を考えて
大学を選びなさい」と
だから 私は 一生懸命考えました
そして 出た答えは
「わからない」でした
自分には 得意なこともないし
好きなこともない
どんな仕事が面白いのか 向いているのか
全くわかりません
何よりも 自分が 社会に役に立てる
自信がありませんでした
自分と社会の間に ガラスがあるような感覚
見えるけど 実感がわかない
志望校が決まっている
まわりの友人に聞いても
将来稼げそうだとか
安定しているとか
曖昧な理由ばかり
大学に行ってから考えればいいよ
という答えもありました
「将来を考えろ」と言っているのに
将来を実感できる機会はない
何のために大学に行くのか わからないまま
勉強だけはさせられる
矛盾していると 当時思いました
だから 仕方なしに つぶしが利く
IT系の学部学科を選び
「とりあえず大学進学」したのです
「とりあえず大学進学」とは
大学進学が普通だからとか
まだ働きたくないとか
他に選択肢がないから というような
消極的な進路選択のことです
日本の大学進学率は
60年前は10％だったのが
今は57％です
それに対し 高卒就職率は
52％だったのが 今は18％です
ちょうど逆になりました
今は 大学進学が 普通になりました
そんな社会は 私たちに
何をもらたしたのでしょうか？
大卒だから得られる 豊かな生活でしょうか？
それとも 専門知識や能力でしょうか？
私は これまで教育に携わり
また 子どもの貧困問題や
奨学金の問題に関わる中で
ある仮説にたどり着きました
それは
「とりあえず大学進学」は
もはや社会的罪ではないか
ということです
今 大学の４年間にかかるお金は
いくらかご存知ですか？
４年間の学費だけで こんなにかかります
50年前は この1/10です
物価の上昇を遥かに上回る 高騰ぶりです
入学費用や通学費 教科書代も入れれば
500万から700万円
子ども一人で 高級車が買えます
いい大学に進学するための
塾通いまで入れれば もっとです
国民の所得は二極化し 今半数の国民は
年収427万円以下で 生活しています
学費はその４割を占めます
せめて大学ぐらい行かせないと
そんな親の想いを踏み台にして
大学進学が 家庭から豊かさを奪っている
一つ目の罪です
そして この「教育にお金がかかる」
という意識が
子どもの数に ブレーキをかけます
二つ目の罪 少子化です
現在 夫婦の約８割が
子どもを増やせない理由に
お金がかかりすぎる を上げています
少子化は 年金問題や介護
労働力不足など
日本の未来の 大きな問題になっています
それだけにとどまりません
「とりあえず大学進学」は
若者の力を削いでしまいます
三つ目の罪です
「とりあえず大学進学」をすると
多くの若者は
大学に入ってからも 目標を持たないまま
大学と家を往復する毎日です
成長実感 手ごたえのないまま
流されるように 時間だけが過ぎていく
そして 気づけば３年生になり
就活地獄が始まります
今 大卒ということだけでは 就職できません
さらに 就職できたと思っても
大卒の３割が ３年以内に辞め
その後 職を転々とする
高卒の離職率は 今は４割ですので
それほど差はありません
そこに加えて 大学生の約半分は
奨学金を借りています
卒業時に平均して300万円
多い人で600万円
1000万円にのぼる人もいます
気づけば 返せないほどの返済地獄
約33万人
10％の人が 滞納しています
奨学金が 若者の力を削いでいます
だから 返済不要の 給付型奨学金を
作る動きもありますが
これだけ 多くの大学進学者に対応する
財源の見通しは ついていません
「無目的で モラトリアムな大学生活も
人生のなかでは重要だ」
という声もあるでしょうが
多額の奨学金を借りてのモラトリアムは
危険な代物です
大学進学が 若者が社会に出るのを遅らせ
成長する力を
無駄にする結果にもなるのです
本来なら 豊かさと能力を
もたらすはずだった大学進学が
人々から豊かさを奪い 少子化を加速させ
若者の力を削いでしまう
３つの社会的罪につながっていることを
私たちは 立ち止まって 見つめる時です
私は 大学進学そのものを
否定したいのではありません
大学でしかできないことは
たくさんありますし
医者や教師 先端科学の研究者など
大学進学が 必須の仕事もあります
私が問題にしたいのは
大学ぐらい出ておかないと将来困る
というような 脅しのような理由や
「とりあえず大学進学」させることを
問題にしたいのです
では どうしたらよいのでしょうか？
大学進学にとらわれない社会を作ることです
そのために不可欠なのは
自分の生き方を選ぶ
「自立」
すなわち
18歳で どの道を選んでも 覚悟をもって
進路選択ができるようにすることです
世界で見ると ごく当たり前のことですが
日本では 大学進学を最優先にするが故に
この自立が遅くなっているのです
自分があり 社会がある
自分がどんな人間で
この社会にどう関われるのか
人は自立する過程で
自分と社会の間で葛藤します
この葛藤の中で 大事なことは
頭の中だけで考えたり
誰かの価値観に囚われるのではなく
自分自身の目で見て 耳で聞いて 肌で感じる
直接体験なのです
社会と自分との間を 行ったり来たりしながら
深く考えていくことで
自己に対する概念―
アイデンティティが作られていきます
これを「探索的体験」と呼んでいます
高校生段階は この自立の過程で
極めて重要な時期です
進学するのか 就職するのか
大学に行くのか 専門学校に行くのか
どの大学にいって 何を学ぶのか
地元に残るか 外へ出るか
他にも 重要な選択が集まっているのが
この高校段階です
これらの選択を 考える材料不足のまま
とりあえずや 仕方なくで
決めさせているのです
今の日本は ７割の高校生が
「自分はダメだ」などの
自己否定感を持っています
他国と比べて これは高い割合です
これでは 将来に向けての選択が
消極的になるのは当然です
だから 彼らには 言葉による励ましではなく
「探索的体験」が必要なのです
社会と繋がる リアルな体験が
気づきや感動 そして
自分も この社会で 何かできるという
自信に変わり
主体的な人生の選択
すなわち「自立」につながります
この 自立への過程を22歳ではなく
18歳までの間に作ること
仕組みを変えていくことが
解決への道なのです
探索的体験は いろいろあります
企業や事業所などで 数日間
実際に働いてみるインターンシップ
関心を持ったテーマや 人の所に行って
話を聞いたりするスタディツアー
グループで 何かの課題に向けて
アクションをする
プロジェクト学習などもあります
学校と社会が連携して
チャンスを用意するだけです
夏休み 冬休み 春休みなど
一回だけでなく
２回 ３回と 何度も繰り返し
学ぶことで深まり
大きく高校生たちを育てるのです
今 すでに 大学生の方は
手遅れではありません
自分の未来について
「わからない」で先送りせず
わからないからこそ 社会に一歩踏み出し
探しに行きましょう
まさに この場がそうですね
探索的体験と自立について
高校生Mさんの例で考えていきます
Mさんは 進学するのが
当たり前の高校にいました
一年の時 友達に誘われて
１万人規模のイベントを
高校生たちが企画実行する
プロジェクトに参加しました
そして 彼女は 他の学校の高校生たちと
多くの困難を乗り越えて
イベントを一緒に成功させます
自分には何かできる
という自信を身につけました
２年生の冬になり
いよいよ進路選択が迫ってきます
家庭の経済的事情で 大学進学は無理と
親から言われていました
大学に行くとしても 多額の奨学金を借りて
自分だけでやれるかといえば
とても不安になります
とはいえ 就職については
情報もあまりなく ネガティブなイメージ
このまま３年生になったら
進学も就職も選べなくなる 行き詰まる
そんな不安を 私たちに語ってくれました
だったら 一度 働いてみないか？と
私はインターンシップを提案しました
そして 彼女は英語が使える仕事に
関心があったので
観光案内所で インターンシップをしました
２日間働いてみたのです
インターンシップ後の感想がこれです
わからないことだらけで焦ったけど
案外通用した
やってなかったから 不安だっただけで
やってみたら 出来る
と 笑顔で 話してくれました
高３になり 国立大学の入試に
トライしましたが 不合格でした
ショックでしたけれども
それで意志を決めました
自分の得意な事はわかっています
何かやれそうな自信もあります
そんな自分を活かせる会社があれば
就職すると決めたのです
私も 一緒に そんな会社を探しました
そして 会社を見つけ 入社試験
これまで 大卒採用していた会社で
高卒採用は初めてです
私もドキドキしましたが
先月 内定がでました
彼女は本当に喜んでいました
その会社の社長は 彼女について
こう感想を言いました
自分をちゃんと持っていて
本当にしっかりしている
今年一番いいと思えるほどだ
充分社会でやっていけるよ
「とりあえず大学進学」をなくすために
もう一つ大事なことは
この社長のように
これまで大卒を採用していた会社が
高卒の価値を見直すこと
そして 高卒を採用し しっかり育てていく
仕組みを作ることです
今 日本は働く世代の
生産人口が激減しています
どこも人材不足に陥っています
「人が採りたくても採れない」と嘆く
企業の声をたくさん聞きます
だったら ダイヤモンドの
原石のような高校生が
たくさんいることに 気づいてください
18歳までの時間があれば
充分に 社会に
通用する人材は育てられます
一つの証拠として
どんな能力で採用するかの
アンケート結果は このとおりです
どこで大学でないと育てられない
能力がありますか？
高校生時代が もっと充実したものになれば
これらの能力は 育むことができます
Mさんは特殊な事例ではありません
普通の高校生が 深い体験を何度も経て
意欲的な若者に 自然に育ったんです
もちろん 高校生ならではの
未熟さもあるでしょう
でも その分 素直さと柔軟性があります
実際に ある企業は 大卒と高卒を採用し
ほぼ同じ研修メニューで
社員教育をしていますが
高卒の方が 素直で吸収力があり 成長が早い
入って３年の21歳でリーダーになる人もいる
と教えてくれました
社会に早く出た分 真剣勝負の現場で磨かれて
ぐんぐん成長していく
その成長力を活かしてください
これまで私たちが抱いてきた
とりあえず大学に行けば なんとかなる
という考えは
過去の遺物です
一つは 高校と社会を繋ぎ
高校生の探索的体験を充実させること
そして もう一つは 高校生が卒業後
企業や社会にダイレクトに入り
自立していく道を 拡げていくことです
社会に早く出て 仕事で力をつけるという
新たな時代の高卒のあり方です
この二つで 大学とか就職とか
それ以外の道を
主体的に選択できる環境になる
そうすれば 大学は とりあえずではなく
目標をもった大学生が集まり
大学教育も 本来の機能を
取り戻すことができる
そんな大学進学を それこそ給付型奨学金で
サポートしたらよいでしょう
社会に出て働いてから
学びたいことが見つかった時に
いつでも学びにいける 社会人大学
というやり方もあるでしょう
就職の選択も 仕方なくではなく
魅力的な社長や会社と出会い
若さと柔軟性を武器に
早く社会に挑戦していく という選択になる
いずれの道も ポジティブで主体的な
選択になるのです
親にとっては高校卒業後の18歳で
我が子が一人の大人として
主体的に自分の道を選択できる
社会になるのは
嬉しいことではないですか？
子どもたち誰もが この社会で
担い手になれる社会に向けて
私たちは 新たな一歩を踏み出す時です
ありがとうございました
(拍手)